de l'église sur une musique de
Marguerite mono les amants d'un jour
[Musique]
moi je suis les Verts au fond du café
j'ai bientôt pas faire pour pouvoir
rêver
et dans ce décor banana
il me semblant encore les voir arriver
[Musique]
dans le soleil ils ont demandé
tu ne vois pas tranquille un tout impose
aimé au cœur de la ville
attendri
[Musique]
[Rires]
chambre d'hôtel
oh papy jolie et quand j'ai fermé la
porte
sur y avait tant de soleil
au fond de leur vie que ça m'a fait mal
que ça
m'a fait mal
moi je suis l'hiver au fond du café
j'ai bien trop affaire pour pouvoir
rêver
[Musique]
et dans ce décor banal la pleurer
ses corps contre le corps qu'on les a
trouvés
[Musique]
on les a trouvé
se donnant par la main les yeux
refermés
dans le soleil on les a couchés
lui est tranquille dans un lit creusé
je rappelle
[Musique]
fermer
ta voix refermé
dans le petit jour
[Musique]
la chambre d'hôtel
des amants d'un jour mais ils m'ont peu
lentilles douleurs
ça me fait mal que ça
me fait mal
moi je suis l'hiver au fond du café
[Musique]
j'ai bientôt pas faire pour pouvoir
rêver
et dans ce décor va dans la pleurer
il y a toujours de
la chambre à louer
[Musique]